let's talk about the war in ukraine and
its impact on the people there
in just three weeks life for millions of
people has become unrecognizable
[Music]
but with so much going on and so many
distressing pictures and stories
flooding our screens it can be hard to
keep track of what's happening where so
let's run you through it
we're going to start with some numbers
that help to show the scale of all of
this
now the u.n has confirmed 691 civilian
deaths but says the real number is
likely much higher and officials from
the city of mariupol alone say 2
500 residents have been killed
ukraine's got a population of 44 million
people around 2 million of them have
left their homes and fled to other parts
of the country mostly to the west
more than 3 million have left ukraine
altogether and crossed into neighboring
countries like poland romania and
moldova
most of them are women and children
because men of military age those
between 18 and 60 are banned from
leaving
them
mother
um
we lost our life
our safety
we can get that plan any future because
we don't know what will be tomorrow
the families i've met here along the
border um they tell me that our plan
basically stops here our plan was to get
to safety and now we have no idea where
we're going next we need shelter we need
an income we need money we need to
survive when it comes to what people
still inside ukraine are dealing with
well it varies depending on where they
are
so far the war has mostly been
concentrated in the north the east and
parts of the south
you can see the areas that russia now
controls and where its forces are
operating
hereson was the first major town they've
managed to take control of
there have been big protests there
against the occupation but also reports
that food and other supplies are running
low and people aren't able to leave
then there are several other towns and
cities that are still holding out
against russian forces but at an
enormous cost
like kharkiv ukraine's second largest
city where entire neighborhoods now lie
in ruins this street in central kharkiv
shows you just how devastating
the effect of russian bombing of this
city has been
an entire street
totally destroyed
i know you can use deep brush
here
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of people did get
out but around half a million are still
there and the shelling hasn't stopped
in the north is another place where
things are really bad and residential
areas are also being bombed
one attack hit a square where people
were lining up for bread local officials
say 47 people died those who are still
living in these besieged areas where
there is intensive you know shelling
fighting going on daily life is very
much about sheltering in a basement and
trying to survive on the food the water
the medicines that you managed to kind
of stock up on before it started the big
problem right now
is to bring the food from where it is to
where it has to go into these cities the
supply chains are completely disrupted
you know bridges have been bombed um um
you know supermarkets are empty trains
you know have been destroyed trucks have
been destroyed drivers are worried to
drive to these places one of the places
people are particularly worried about is
mario pol which has been almost totally
cut off with around 400 000 trapped
there it's surrounded by russian forces
and for the last two weeks they've been
attacking relentlessly
this is where there was an attack on a
maternity hospital which ukraine's
president has called a war crime
there are reports of bodies lying in the
streets and the authorities have
resorted to mass graves to bury the dead
there's no running water
food and medicine are running out
shops and pharmacies have been looted
communications are down there's no
electricity and it's freezing cold
there have been attempts to get a
ceasefire in place so that people can
get out and aid can get into mariopol
but they haven't really worked
so far only 2 000 cars have been able to
escape
another 2 000 are still waiting to leave
according to city officials
meanwhile the rest of the country is
watching what's going on in places like
mariupol and kharkiv and they're bracing
for the worst too especially in the
capital kiev where russian forces are
closing in and the fight is getting
closer
[Music]
now that's the entrance of a residential
building here in the north of kiev
and just take a look at the damage you
can still actually smell the burning
the center of the city has been heavily
fortified
shops are mainly closed
half of the city's population is left
according to the mayor
and those who have stayed are mostly
sheltering in places like basements and
metro stations
for those who remain and kiev life has
moved deep on the ground here they hope
to be safe from russian bombs and
missiles but they're all holding their
breath for what's coming next
okay now let's look at what's going on
in the west of ukraine there's no big
presence of russian forces there
although there have been some attacks
mostly targeting military facilities
levieve is the main city in the west and
it's still functioning relatively
normally there's a nighttime curfew but
during the day people are out on the
streets and going to work
livia has also become a hub for ngos and
a transit point for supplies coming into
the country in western parts of ukraine
everything is more or less okay and you
can buy all necessary things in the
supermarket or shops and actually what
we are doing right now here in even our
cities we are buying and getting
everything what we can get and trying to
send it to kiev to other cities
especially
in
eastern part of ukraine but leve is also
dealing with the arrival of hundreds of
thousands of people who fled from other
parts of the country it's a huge
displacement crisis people there have
two basic strategies the first one is to
stay in a relatively stable part of the
ukraine or
they stay just for two days and continue
further west to slovakia or poland even
if western ukraine is relatively stable
now
will that last there is certainly a
growing sense of unease here in the city
of levith because in previous nights
there were air raid sirens which
sometimes lasted as long as three hours
and we know that those sirens are linked
to the increased number of russian
attacks on targets in western ukraine in
each discussion i had here
during the last
10 days
there was just one word we want peace we
want peace to come home
because we want
to live our normal lives as we did
before this russian invasion
if you missed it check out our last
episode about why nato is ruling out a
no-fly zone for ukraine click the link
here to watch and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel so you
don't miss our upcoming episodes
[Music]